missing data may be the most interesting
thing in the whole data mining so just
to clarify something
and I say missing data in the
immigration video we were talking about
data that's unobtainable I don't mean
that I mean data which you could obtain
it but it's missing so that was the
unknown that's right now we just talk
about things like you could know it but
for whatever reason it's just not there
let's start at the beginning I mean you
might go missing data hold on I heard is
the world of big data we could data
coming out of our ears what do you mean
missing data yeah yeah the data is
getting bigger and data is everywhere
because we have centers embedded in
everything these days for example and
there's surveys all the time and
everything is recorded forevermore so
there's more and more data that of
trouble is the quality of the data is
actually going down and down I mean
years and years ago times when I was
doing my PhD for example we had these
tiny small data sets and they were hand
curated and it was like wouldn't
wonderfully crafted and everybody was
checked in was on you haven't got time
for that anymore now data gets collected
Russia Russia Russia and you know and of
course what happened this Center goes
wrong something doesn't quite get
collected somebody goes on a cigarette
break and doesn't take your temperature
whatever this sort of thing but also it
can be can be completely a completely
good reason I'm just going to show you
another example why data can be missing
on my screen here I've got a data set
from a hospital where we talking about
colon cancer patients and if they told
500 people lots of lots of different
measurements have been taken from them
over the years if you look through this
you'll see that it's quite a few blanks
here and for some patients seem to be
completely blank what happens over the
years is technology changes I mean
there's some tests available now that
just didn't exist ten years ago so of
course for the patients now we have some
data we just didn't have ten years ago
it's missing but it can't be much about
it also patients don't turn up on
appointment the data's missing or I mean
a lot of these things are done by
biological sampling and sometimes the
chemicals don't work the guy looks
through the microscope he doesn't like
it they answer and you know so all sorts
of things also I mean if you're talking
about things like a survey for example
somebody might just not wanna give the
answer I don't know the answer so a lots
of reasons why data can be missing now
what do we do about missing data and why
am I going to try and tell you this is
really interesting I mean okay let's do
the basics first missing data you might
go well okay well just go back and get
it in okay well possible I mean it
depends what you're doing I mean we've
done a project with
HQ the security with you you will hear a
bit about this or maybe he just become
aware of a zero-day attack somebody
nobody else knows yet and he really
there we collected a relatively small
amount of data from experts and there
was one or two answers missing and we've
really wanted those answers so yeah we
went back to the experts because you
knew who they were where we said look
you forgot to answer this question Kay
just tell us the answer that's all right
we can do this with one or two things
they can't do this like for hundreds and
hundreds of things I mean in a hospital
they can defrost some samples and I can
try and sample them again there's a lot
of effort a lot of money goes into this
I think you normally do this so yeah
maybe you can go back fill in the blanks
but it's not realistic not for any large
scale thing next then what else can you
do I just ignore the missing values then
you know who cares you know well okay so
let's take this example here of my of my
500 patients on the hospital in the
hospital this is probably the UK's best
dataset in colon cancer
now from the 500 patients about 90% of
them have got one volume missing or
other for all the reasons I mentioned so
if you just got rid of everybody who's
got a bit of missing data we're left
with 10% of the data completely no point
anymore to analyze it okay fine well
swell now maybe you think okay maybe you
shouldn't get rid of the data it's just
a little bit of data is missing that's
fine just get rid of the ones where
there's a lot of data missing oh that
sounds like a nice idea but I'll just
straight up to you so let's imagine this
is how a day turning is like oh well you
know attributes for six seven eight nine
and then a my example there is 200 of
them and then we could our patients 1 2
3 4 5 and in my example there's 500 of
them we've got this enormous matrix or
table of data and you know the odd value
is missing so there's a few missing if
you're missing it for some of them a bit
more dismissing any kind of what it
looks like it's all right so you know
who should we ignore okay you go all
right let's guess it with other ones
would have a lot of data missing do you
mean the columns or the rows where do we
start because and you're certain you're
Zod realize you actually end up with
something which is a giant Sudoku kind
of thing because like okay well if we
cancel this one out then actually how
many X's have you got left in these
columns now and I feel aunt Elizabeth
I suddenly cancel this one but now this
one doesn't look so bad anymore because
we cancel that one and also you will
find this a lot of them have the same
number of data items missing because
they maybe miss the same number of tests
so which if then do we get rid of and
then depending which when you delete
first you
somebody different in fact what you can
share is this is an optimization problem
in itself which is harder solving the
data mining problem so that it's not
there's no easy way of just deleting a
few because which few and you did need
some ideally some different bones we pay
for analyze the data we get different
answers again pointless so deleting the
data that's missing nice idea and might
work if you could huge amounts of data
and little bit is missing but in reality
it's actually really really hard okay
right convinced you now we need to do
something about missing data what can we
do about missing data but it's a date
anything at random was it missing not at
random and that's why it gets starts get
interesting
so give you some examples let's say for
a particular patient one of the blood
values is missing and it's missing
because the test failed a chemical
failed almost certainly this is
completely at random it's just a
chemical failed in this particular
moment and there's a random random
failure fine another example might be if
you do fill in the survey and you for
example
asking for income of people and
somewhere else in the survey you're also
asking what's your mental state at the
moment are you happy or you're not so
happy and what happens is a lot of
people don't really want to say what
their income is because they're bit shy
about income but actually the people not
so happy are probably even more shy
about their income because you haven't
got so much income so what happens is
it's kind of random what's missing
because it's randomly missing but
there's a bit of a correlation on
happening between some of the things how
do we deal with missing data we can
probably fill it in somehow for example
I could calculate the mean of the date
of everybody else and wherever the data
is missing I put a mean volume that's a
classic approach of filling in missing
value if my data before looked something
like this and now I've got a number of
people where the number is missing and I
put the meaning of course afterwards my
day table looks something like this
weren't it because suddenly I've given
everybody who had something missing this
middle value the argument is if it's
completely missing at random that's a
somewhat acceptable way of doing it
because I'm not changing any of the
distributions now but it's not ideal
because I get this peak in there and
actually the data it's not as diverse
anymores before so better way of filling
in a missing value would be I give me
the middle value but plus mine is a bit
of an error and then probably I go from
something like this to something a bit
more like maybe looks like this
and that's quite acceptable
now what if it not missing completely
random well if it's not missing
completely at random then and I do this
I'm kind of distorting the data because
I'm putting in something random it
shouldn't be but of course but I can do
is I can have use a bit of domain
knowledge and go okay income is missing
for some people because they don't wanna
give this value but it's kind of
connected to your mental state and I
know different mental states of
different incomes and I can build a bit
of a correlation model where basically
if your mental state is this then I give
you the medium income of those sort of
people if your mental state is that I
give you the median income of the other
group of people well that's better that
makes it quite a nice thing maybe I can
do it for men and women for example I
can do it for all the young people or I
can just see what does it relate to the
missing thing why do we need to fill in
these missing values actually why not
just let's just not do anything at all
because a lot of software can't handle
it a lot of machine learning needs to
have a value there if a blank it just
breaks so we need something there and if
you think your software can deal with it
it probably behind the lines does
something with the blank so so far this
is all kind of still a bit yeah ok
missing value is calculating missing
values ok it's a bit of interesting now
it's not that interesting yet where it
gets properly interesting is when the
value is not missing it randomly at all
and that very often is actually part of
the answer that you need for the whole
data mining problem let's take another
example let's say you're an insurance
company and one of the bate data item
should be collected to driving the
license number and of course I only want
to give insurance to people who really
have a driving licence now if you don't
tell me your driving license number
might well be because you haven't
actually got a driving licence so you
just to sort of person I need to date a
mine and not give a insurance to or
really expensive insurance maybe so not
having the value of and it's not random
at all might actually be the data that
you need to mine now because we can't
mine a missing value it's not possible
in this case what we can do is we can do
something like a sensor value it's
called so they give you something like a
minus one for example or two five five
or something like this where all the
missing values get replaced if they send
it it just means that I can sort on this
value and I can then data mine on it now
I need to be careful because I need to
understand why is the body missing but
if it's missing for this reason that
could be very good now the last thing
and this is very guess perhaps the most
interesting is where the day
isn't missing at all but it's really
missing I do this all the time and I'm
sure these all the time we have to fill
in questionnaires and I don't really
want to give the real data for the
bloody questionnaire it doesn't let me
finish without putting in a number so I
need to put in something and I often put
it into something random more people do
this in questionnaires so it might be
something like my telephone number is
nine nine nine nine nine nine
I don't want anybody calling me thank
you very much or number of children
minus one because you know I don't want
to tell you it cetera et cetera so what
happens is I do data mining and Damali
isn't missing because there's a number
there but of course the number is
completely false it's wrong and really
it's missing so what I need to do is two
stages here I need to do a basic data
mining maybe something unsupervised
where I find all these outliers and then
I can either delete the outliers and
replace them with something more
sensible or maybe having found the
outliers I'm actually finished because
if I want to find all the people not to
give insurance - well you lie about the
telephone number but no what else are
you lying about so maybe you're just
sore person you shouldn't give you the
insurance and the finger vein reader
rather than just a traditional
fingerprint reader actually searches for
signs of life so has to make sure that
you have an edge of finger cough that
someone's brought you through so it's
quite extreme the other way these
methods usually work is to actually
start off by saying but how many groups
would you like your data to be and how
many clusters would you like